and today's starting pitcher for the
tigers is ronnie garcia ronnie's making
his major league debut along with a
couple of his teammates yesterday it's
time getting back in the box after that
close shave weights on a 1-2
slow roller to third cut off by
candelario nice play
tigers retire whitmer field about that
raise the flag chef
mom does he owe for five last night
on the ground cj krohn gobbles it up
there's two for the tigers well done
good first inning for the rookie ronnie
garcia
franco at the plate i'm liking what i
see out of ronnie garcia so far he's
really just pounding that strike zone
he's confident kid
got him looking save the baseball first
strikeout at the major league level
austin romine off to a 3 for 10 start
with a home run breaking ball is lined
and it's caught by whit he leaped high
in the air was able to pull it out of
the sky
so zimmer gets out of a jam in the
second inning we head to the third stew
will have the call for you we're still
looking for our first run with hernandez
at third phillips at second whitmerfield
with an rbi opportunity
there's the fly ball to left field
stewart is back he is all the way back
it is gone for a three run home
[Laughter]
another rookie pitcher in his debut
giving up a home run to a royal shock
the house you know
just smart he took a
swing at the first pitch was a slider
middle but he's there to swing he's
there to knock in runs jacobi five for
14 with a couple of home runs so far
bottom of the third three-nothing kansas
city the 2-0 oh
man hit him in the helmet with a 93 mile
an hour fastball jacoby down now up onto
a knee doug teeter tigers had trainers
running out from the dugout fastball hit
him squarely
in the helmet
on the left side it looked like you can
see him kind of working his jaw
jeez
he got hit
in chicago memorably a few years ago
same thing it's good to see that he's
staying in the ball game if it wasn't
for that ear flap right he would
probably have a broken jaw right now
he's gonna make a move kyle zimmer exits
with nobody down here in the third
jonathan scope stands in after grounding
to third back in the first
another one to center
phillips racing back that ball is gone
over the bushes a two-run shot his first
as a tiger well good for sculpey right
there jonathan scope to straight away
center road the wind a little bit and it
just kept carrying over the 420 marker a
two run shot tigers now trailed 3-2 here
in the third here's kristen stewart who
flew out to center his first time up
first pitch swinging
lifting it to deep left center field
phillips going back that ball's gone
kristen stewart pushes the tigers in
front with a two-run blast well there's
his first hit of the season and a day in
the right christian stewart follows up
in the same inning fastball of tails out
on the outer part of the plate christian
gets good extension and balls are
carrying here at comerica park tonight
back into their bullpen a guy we saw
last night the fourth pitcher of the
night josh stamont 01 oh and that hit
him in the head
jacoby jones
was hit in the head or in the face in
the third and now here in the fifth
jonathan scope is hit on top of the
helmet and actually he ducked right down
into it
but you're really taught to duck down
and then turn your shoulder if your
right hand hit her that left shoulder he
was trying yeah
but that ball followed him he followed
him didn't yeah
he couldn't hide so two on four three
tigers man on second two outs we're in
the bottom of the fifth inning that
brings up cj crone
that clips crone
curveball again jonathan just let it hit
him really third hit by pitch for the
royals pitching against the tigers here
tonight but this one again a curveball
that just spun got away see cronie just
lets it hit up in the elbow we head to
the top of the ninth inning joe jimenez
is in joe seems to
be in control here to start this at that
the one-two
on the ground cut off by candelario nice
third dandy of a play he's made tonight
i'm about to pick it right now danny
yeah how about the leather that's been
behind too we talk about the pitching
but defense goes hand in hand the guys
have really done a nice job defensively
tonight really the entire season
alberto mondezi
first pitch swinging pops it up on the
infield
who wants it
it's cj come on and he dropped it
he's got it he's stranded
they got him that's heads up right there
by jonathan scope that's a break oh boy
two quick outs he's got to finish off
salvador perez 202 blows that way
put it in the books jimenez retires the
royals one two three
and detroit
gets to three and two on the season
couple of two run homers for the tigers
in the third
one from jonathan scope
and one from kristen stewart the tigers
bullpen puts together six shutout
innings facing one batter over the
minimum